at this point adding a new method to the
car class is as easy as modifying one
line of code and then it'll
automatically be available on the object
if you're not familiar with the syntax
of extend you should look up an
implementation that's made available in
one of the many open-source libraries
that build this for you but know that it
is not a native JavaScript function so
to keep our examples simple we're gonna
go back to the old version of the code
that only had one method to add to every
car let's go back to our diagram in
these most recent edits we have gone
from having a move variable that stored
a function object to instead having a
methods variable that stores an object
and that object has a move property
pointing to the same function you could
say that this is better because the
methods object is now capable of storing
as many different methods as you want to
have available on every car instance one
problem I'm noticing with this code is
that the named methods doesn't seem to
make it very clear that the methods
object is affiliated in some way with
the car class we could easily confuse it
as being perhaps a method container for
some other class furthermore in the
current code it's a global variable
which is something we should avoid it
would be nice if the methods object was
clearly encapsulated somehow along with
the car class function such that the two
of them were bundled up together nice
and neat but it's just as easy to store
an object like this methods object as a
property of another object as it is to
store it in a global variable so let's
use the object features of the car
function to make room for the object
that stores these methods instead of
using a global variable called methods
we will instead put a property on the
car function called dot methods